frustration at the dmv the nevada dmv
switched to appointment only services to
make things more efficient for customers
but as mary jane belliesa reports some
customers are frustrated trying to book
these online appointments
it's been about two months since the
department of motor vehicles have
switched over to appointments only for
many services but some eight news now
viewers have reached out to me saying
they haven't been able to schedule an
appointment at all tabitha gerkin has
been trying to register her late
father's truck in her name along with
trying to schedule a drive test for her
two teens on the truck it's been about
two months and on the one license has
been three if you forget something or if
it's outdated
you have to come back that's exactly
what happened to gherkin i thought for a
simple title change i could just come do
it you have to have the vehicle to have
the vin inspected but there's no
checklist that really tells you
exactly what you need an employee
shortage and high customer demand has
led to the appointment only policy dmv
officials say appointments are booked
four weeks out we take about a hundred
phone calls a week from individuals that
cannot get through to the dmv sarah
marks owns my car lady dmv registration
services she knows the frustrations her
clients face she struggled herself to
book an appointment to renew her car
registration what we're getting is a
huge influx of individuals who cannot
wait the month or two for a registration
appointment a lot of individuals don't
know how to navigate the computer they
don't want to put their information in
there or they simply can't find what
they're looking for walk-in services
will remain the same on saturdays and
dmv officials are urging people to check
the website first if you can do that
service online reporting from henderson
mary jane vallieza 8 news now
as she mentioned people do cancel and
reschedule appointments so look a few
times a day on the website for any
openings and at various locations the
dmv is also trying to address the
employee shortage you can submit your
resume to dmv.nv.gov
even if there are no openings listed on
the state website the dmv does build
some internal lists based on required
positions